parce qu'on appelle le revers tu vois ça
peut être plus facile toi c'est ce qui
fait là-bas ils tiennent une raquette
dans leurs mains pour la première fois
les enfants de la communauté des gens du
voyage se sont précipités pour
participer à cette initiation au
badminton
mais vraiment c'est bien vraiment
j'adore vraiment je suis fan de ça et
après c'est vrai que c'est quand même
fatiguant mais c'est vrai que ça donne
envie de continuer les jeux de plein air
ces enfants ils sont habitués toute
l'année cette fois l'activité sportive
est dispensée par des professionnels
ça nous permet que nos enfants aussi
sort de notre de leur cocon familial et
de pouvoir expérimenter des choses qui
ne connaissent pas encore et que nous on
n'a pas eu la chance justement de
pouvoir connaître à notre époque
l'accueil des gens du voyage à La
Ferté-Imbault est récent le sport comme
vecteur de lien social l'idée est venue
à Madame le Maire pour favoriser leur
intégration on peut pas dire qu'il soit
tous bienvenue sur les territoires
français donc je me suis dit quitte à ce
qu'il soit là autant le bien vivre
ensemble autant que ça se passe bien et
donc je pense que le sport a véhicule
des valeurs et donc j'aurais proposé de
que les enfants jouent et avec voilà
avec la Ligue du badminton et la Ligue
du Centre c'est bien volontiers déplacée
dans ce petit village sologno labellisé
terre de jeux 2024 le but c'est avec
l'objectif des Jeux Olympiques 2024 de
faire découvrir le sport au plus grand
nombre et c'est vrai que voilà un
campement Jean du voyage comme comme
celui-ci c'est pas des
réflexion qu'on fait de manière
habituelle je pense que même pour les
autres disciplines ça se fait pas trop
puis on a eu envie de faire une belle
action il fait super beau et ben on voit
que les enfants sont super contents en
attendant 2024 les enfants pourront
continuer s'ils le souhaitent à jouer au
sein du club de badminton dans le
gymnase tout neuf de la Ferté